[Music]  Lala and Carmelo Anthony are separating  according to reports I know mellow and I  have a strong foundation we have a great  relationship and that's what matters I  don't get caught up in all that outside  stuff because I know what goes on behind  closed doors and that's what matters to  me the couple has been together for more  than 13 years hey see I gotta go get my  wedding dress on I'll see you guys at  the wedding they tied the knot in 2010  and share one child their 10 year old  son cayenne now that I'm a mom just that  unconditional love it's like nothing  that a woman could ever feel in her life  Lala last shared a photo with Carmelo  two months ago for Valentine's Day this  split news comes after reports surfaced  that the New York Knicks will likely  trade carmelo to another team this year  while la la is focused on her acting  career she currently stars on power  always trying to elevate and figure out  what the next day  [Music]  you